[Musica]
si stima che per produrre una t shirt in
cotone siano necessari 2.700 litri
d'acqua questa quantità e quella che
ciascuno di noi dovrebbe bere per due
anni e mezzo
ma l'industria della moda non solo
consuma acqua ma la inquina anche si
stima che il 20 per cento
dell'inquinamento totale dell'acqua
deriva dall industria tessile a causa
dei processi di lavorazione del capo
quali finitura e tintura a questo si
aggiunge anche un 35 per cento di
rilascio di microplastiche a causa
dell'appoggio dei capi si stima inoltre
che l'industria della moda sia
responsabile del 10 per cento di
emissioni di co2 una quantità pari
all'intero trasporto marittimo e agli
interi trasporti i voli internazionali
come siamo arrivati a tutto ciò
abbiamo pensato che acquistare un capo
quella famosa t shirt di cotone per soli
5 euro fosse una cosa normale e forse
per questo ci siamo anche sentiti un po
in diritto di poterla utilizzare poche
volte e poi buttarla via
nel 1996 il consumo di capi all'interno
dell'unione europea è aumentato del 40
per cento
proprio a causa della riduzione dei
prezzi e oggi ogni cittadino europeo
consuma ogni anno 26 kg di capi ma la
cosa ben peggiore è che 11 kg di questi
26 ogni anno devono essere smaltiti
peccato che soltanto l'un per cento di
questa quantità riesce ad essere
riconvertita in un nuovo capo
la restante la restante parte viene
smaltita principalmente nelle discariche
un bel problema
ma potremo sempre donarla in qualche
paese più povero come in africa
ogni anno dall occidente ma anche dalla
cina arrivano tonnellate e tonnellate di
capi da donare in africa
e questa è una convenzione talmente
ormai consolidata che ci sono alcuni
paesi africani che hanno anche dato un
nome a questi capi
sapete cosa vuol dire a cannes o broni
wow
questa è un'espressione che hanno
definito in ghana per descrivere i capi
morti dell'uomo bianco
ma la qualità dei capi oggi ormai è
diventata talmente bassa che il 50 per
cento dei capi che arriva qui deve
essere direttamente smaltito perché non
più utilizzabile e quindi questo va
ingolfare le discariche presenti in
questi paesi e per di più ad avere un
impatto molto negativo sulla eco sistema
tessile locale
e cosa ne pensiamo poi a di quei
bellissimi maglioncini di cashmere che
possiamo prendere
acquistare per 50 euro
dal 1949 al 2004 il numero di capre
allevati in mongolia è cresciuto del
mille per cento e questo ha creato degli
enormi problemi nel paese a causa di un
estensione della desertificazione
con un impatto a livello climatico molto
importante nonché sull'economia e sulla
società
locale
spaventoso non è vero
è quello che ho pensato io qualche anno
fa sei anni fa quando dopo aver lavorato
per alcuni anni con l'innovazione e la
tecnologia sono arrivata in questo mondo
in questo fantastico mondo della moda
ero entusiasta perché certamente mi
aspettavo di trovare un mondo fatto di
bellezza di creatività di cura al
dettaglio
ed è certo la mi aspettavo di sentire
parlare di rifiuti l'inquinamento e
anche di condizioni lavorative a volte
molto svantaggiose
e allora mi sono detta
devo fare qualcosa o posso far qualcosa
e come faccio a farlo non sono una
creativa certamente l'unica cosa che
potevo fare e cercare di poter investire
le risorse che avevamo in
innovazione e tecnologia che potesse
rendere il sistema della moda non solo
un industria più innovativa ma anche più
responsabile e quindi iniziato un po a
guardarmi intorno e a capire che c'erano
in realtà altri operatori
innovatori aziende
regolatori che stanno cercando di andare
proprio in questa direzione
oggi la consapevolezza che l'industria
della moda a questo enorme problema
fortunatamente c'è e abbiamo iniziato a
capire che per rendere la moda una
industria più sostenibile è necessario
pensare fin dall'inizio fin dal momento
in cui andiamo a disegnare il capo a
fare in modo che qualsiasi elemento che
venga introdotto all'interno del capo
possa essere poi reintegrato all'interno
del ciclo produttivo
stiamo parlando di una moda circolare ma
come facciamo ad arrivare lì
partiamo dai dalle materie prime le
materie prime sono responsabili per il
20 per cento dell'impatto ambientale
dell'industria della moda oggi abbiamo
alcune soluzioni ad esempio abbiamo la
possibilità di utilizzare delle fibre
che derivano da elementi riciclati come
ad esempio il poliestere riciclato il
poliestere riciclato deriva dal riciclo
di bottigliette di plastica
principalmente o prodotti di plastica in
generale oggi questa fibra
rappresenta il 14 per cento del poli
essere totale ed un risparmio di energia
del 60 per cento
una cosa simile l'abbiamo su in nylon
un'azienda italiana ha sviluppato una
tecnologia capace di riconvertire scarti
di nylon come le reti da pesca in una
nuova fibra di nylon riciclato ma una
cosa molto interessante
la stiamo guardando da start up
innovative che hanno stanno trovando
delle metodologie per poter riconvertire
materiale organico
scarti di materiali organici magari
derivanti da industrie agricole e
agroalimentari
i nuovi tessuti e il caso di questa
azienda siciliana che utilizza scarti di
arance quindi dal processo
agroalimentare per poter sviluppare
attraverso una metodologia dei tessuti
che sono molto simili alla cellulosa
quindi andando ad evitare di utilizzare
la polpa di legno per ottenere lo stesso
tessuto
oppure un'azienda americana che invece è
sviluppato un metodo per utilizzare
scarti di foglie di ananas
dall'azienda dalla industria agricola
per poter poi andare a sviluppare dei
tessuti che sono molto simili alla pelle
e possiamo immaginare qual è l'impatto
ambientale è molto importante che la
pelle può generare poi abbiamo anche una
cosa estremamente interessante ci sono
alcuni novatori che hanno capito che può
essere molto efficace andare ad
osservare quello che accade in natura e
cercare di replicarlo in laboratorio è
il caso di questa azienda americana che
ha trovato la soluzione per riuscire a
far crescere delle cellule all'interno
della di un laboratorio in modo da
trasformarle in fibre di cotone e
risparmio che si riesce ad ottenere
attraverso questa soluzione è
dell'ottanta per cento di acqua ora
ricordiamoci i 2.700 litri d'acqua per
produrre la t shirt bene lascio
calcolare a voi quale potrebbe essere
l'impatto grandioso che questa soluzione
potrebbe portare una volta arrivato sul
mercato
un'azienda inglese invece ha avuto
un'intuizione fondamentale
i fondatori hanno guardato un po la
natura e si sono resi conto che questa è
piena di colori
e allora l'intuizione è stata perché non
andare ad individuare delle piante degli
insetti dei microrganismi
che hanno il suo al loro interno dei
colori quindi una pigmentazione e quindi
hanno fatto hanno sviluppato questa
soluzione
anno attraverso i cinque sequenziamento
del dna
estratto il gene che conteneva il
pigmento all'interno della della pianta
per esempio e sono riusciti poi a
stampare questo gene contenente
l'informazione del colore su
microrganismi
in questo modo attraverso un processo di
fermentazione che è molto simile a
quello che succede con la birra quindi
mettendo questi microrganismi sui
lieviti e su zuccheri dopo li hanno
fatti riprodurre ovviamente molto
velocemente e quindi alla fine del
processo invece che ottenere una bella
bottiglia di birra fresca
ottengono questa bottiglia di colore che
può essere utilizzata per tingere i capi
le cose belle anche in questo caso è un
risparmio importante di acqua ma anche
si va ad evitare di utilizzare sostanze
chimiche tossiche che in genere il
processo di tintura comporta il secondo
step della catena dell'area industria
della moda che comporta un forte impatto
a livello ambientale e quello del fine
vita ovvero cosa facciamo dei capi una
volta che li abbiamo utilizzati
oggi è molto difficile riuscire a
riciclare capi vi dicevo soltanto l'un
per cento viene riconvertito i nuovi
capi e questo perché ora provate a
guardare i capi che avete su su oggi è
vedere l'etichetta vi renderete conto
che in realtà la gran parte dei capi
presentano una composizione mista di
fibre
poi essere cotone anche un po di last
omero e questo non è perché i creativi
si divertono a mischiare un po le cose
ma perché chiaramente diverse fibre
hanno diverse funzionalità
peccato però che questo comporta un
estrema difficoltà nel riuscire poi a
riciclare il capo proprio perché ad oggi
non esiste una tecnologia
economicamente fattibile per poter
sempre separare le fibre inoltre la
separazione richiede dei processi
chimici tenderebbero ad introdurre altri
altre sostanze sulla sul sul ciclo di
vita del capo tuttavia anche qua
fortunatamente la tecnologia sta ci sta
arrivando
ho visto una soluzione che consente di
inserire
immaginiamoci in un bioreattore un
tessuto di fibre miste quindi ad esempio
poi essere e cotone e in questo caso si
riesce a separare la fibra e a
smaltire il cotone
trasformandolo in catene di zuccheri e
gli zuccheri in bioetanolo quindi una
nuova energia che può essere
reintrodotta nel ciclo produttivo
e dobbiamo fare in fretta sul riciclo
questo perché il 2018
in questo caso sono i regolatori che ci
danno una mano c'è l'unione europea ha
emanato una direttiva
che ci dice che dal primo gennaio 2025
sarà necessario per i paesi all'interno
dell'unione europea smaltire i tessuti
quindi nella raccolta differenziata
avremo anche la raccolta dei tessuti
ora quello che leggete lì non leggete
perché ho sbagliato a scrivere in realtà
e dobbiamo essere molto orgogliosi
l'italia ha deciso di anticipare di ben
tre anni l'entrata in vigore di questa
normativa
quindi a gennaio tra pochi mesi
l'italia dovrebbe introdurre questo
obbligo
per cui speriamo che la tecnologia
riesca a darci qualche qualche soluzione
a breve
e poi in realtà che ha detto che i capi
dobbiamo per forza produrli fisicamente
indossarli
anche in questo caso è la tecnologia da
una parte la creatività che vengono a
darci una mano oggi abbiamo la
possibilità di acquistare dei capi che
sono solo virtuali
come li indossiamo naturalmente
attraverso la realtà aumentata
quindi stiamo parlando di capi che
potremo indossare sui no sulle nostre
foto sui nostri video e quindi sui
nostri canali social essendo dei capi
non fisici la cosa bella è che non
devono rispondere alle leggi della
fisica quindi la creatività ha un
grandissimo spazio possiamo avere dei
capi con delle scintille di fuoco
tutti illuminati dei capi che non
rispondono alle leggi della gravità
quindi la creatività ha davvero dei
nuovi spazi per poter lavorare
e un ultimo elemento che manca l'appello
è quello della finanza oggi per poter
riuscire a raggiungere i target che da
una parte i regolatori e dall'altra
anche le aziende si sono imposti per il
mancano all'appello tra i 20 ei 30
miliardi di euro per poter riuscire a
sviluppare queste tecnologie che a volte
sono ancora in laboratorio e portare sul
mercato
fortunatamente anche in questo caso
iniziano ad esserci una serie di fondi
di investitori che hanno capito quanto
sia importante non solo riuscire ad
avere un ritorno finanziario nel breve
ma anche investire per avere un ritorno
sull'ambiente un impatto sociale nel
medio e lungo termine
manca ancora un elemento
la tecnologia è molto veloce ma
sicuramente non riuscirà mai a
rincorrere i nostri consumi forsennati
oggi
acquistare un capo e utilizzarlo per
poche volte non è cool lasciate che ve
lo dica non è più di moda
oggi sicuramente
se volete essere cool
quello che dovete fare è
acquisti acquistare un capo e curarlo
prendervi cura del capo
magari rivenderlo sui mercati di second
hand magari ripararlo un po ricordiamoci
quello che facevano le nostre famiglie
fino a pochi anni fa
perché credo che molti di voi siano
appassionati del mondo della moda non ci
lavorano magari
sono sono semplicemente appassionati lo
siamo lo siamo un po tutti per cui oggi
se vogliamo continuare a ricordare la
moda come un mondo pieno di colori un
mondo che ci fa sognare un mondo che
esalta anche un po noi stessi e le
differenze tra noi
beh dobbiamo fare qualcosa e possiamo
contribuire
impegniamoci tutti a fare questo e non
facciamo in modo di ricordare la moda
solo perché in cui il nostro pianeta
grazie
[Applauso]